our Conan in Haiti special aired last
Saturday night we're all really proud of
it if you did miss it you can still see
it go to Team Coco calm /pd
yes yes sir so you really visited Haiti
huh yes I'd yes I did yeah we made a
show about it yeah and you've also
visited Cooper Armenia South Korea and
also other places yes yes sir traveling
is a big part of the show now we love to
travel yeah then you should come to my
country next hello my name is Francisco
googley only and I am the president of
Bolivia Kwai belivet way I've never
never heard of it it is definitely a
real place just look at this map I'm
sorry it looks like you just drew on a
map with a sharpie anyway
absolutely must come to believe away it
is only a 39 hour flight
I'm sorry 39 hour flight yes yes you'll
fly from Los Angeles to Sydney to Los
Angeles to belittle great it's a weird
customs thing okay sir
I'm sorry I cannot visit Bulova Quay and
I'm sorry that's right you can't visit
until you get your shots you see
philippic way was recently ranked number
one by the global Center for definitely
real diseases well then I'm definitely
not visiting fine I will let them offer
you there's too many hands disease the
disappointing tingles Geoff breath total
struggle confusion resting [ __ ] ankle
banana syndrome penile senility some
heiner's disease face pocalypse and
listing fake diseases disease which is
what I suffered from yes and Senna
mr. president look look around we're
okay no no don't don't look anywhere I'm
just an expression mr. president I am
NOT visiting your country okay okay fine
but what if I kept talking anyway I
don't think I still am the beloved liebe
liver going international airport on the
side of an active volcano okay
I don't know that looks kind of
dangerous only on the eruption Tuesday's
then you'll travel to the capital of
Bolivia quai but live Acropolis and
you'll get there in style vias ziplining
donkey there's I'm sorry there's no way
that that worked
sure it does you ride the donkey and the
donkey ziplines why not just let the
people zipline without sitting on a
donkey sure and when I just let the
passengers fly the airplane back right
anyway your first stop simple little
waffle it will be the crazy dance
Institute I have a feeling you'll get a
pretty good segment out of that place
then you'll visit the wall where
everyone cries oh my god
I'm sure does that wall have some deep
historical significance no it's made of
onions
then for the last eight days of the trip
you will relax in the woods okay what do
you mean
relax in the woods we will just leave
you in the woods for eight days where
you can relax no no I'm sorry being lost
in the woods is not relaxing he's in
bulimic way where the woods are
positively infested with wild masseuses
Wow I'm sorry I'm still not coming I do
have one question sir why all the metals
oh these that's simple in belivet way
you'll receive a medal for every bowel
movement no dammit
okay what's what's wrong
[Music]
all right that's disgusting I I think it
should just go we'll see you in the back
wait no no I
[Applause]
you
you